you're on a beach not a worry in the
world the Sun bronzing your skin Sam
trickling between your toes the sound of
waves wait what
where did all the water go did you see
it going out now what better act quickly
in a matter of minutes you may be
underwater here's what you can do to
survive a tsunami tsunamis are triggered
by intense underwater activity usually
an earthquake or an underwater volcanic
eruption
these events displace huge volumes of
water pushing it up from the oceans
floor to its surface but when gravity
pulls it back down all this built-up
energy is released outwards forming
deadly waves that grow stronger as they
ripple across the ocean a tsunamis waves
can be 100 kilometres long and sometimes
taller than 30 metres they can travel
across whole oceans moving at the speed
of a jet airplane so with such speed
strength and stamina how does anyone
stand a chance even in a tsunami hazard
zone you can still survive if you know
what to do the first step to survival is
to be able to identify the early signs
of a tsunami the Pacific Ocean is home
to volatile tectonic activity which
explains why 75% of the world's volcanic
eruptions and 90% of the world's
earthquakes occur in the Pacific these
geological disturbances are the reason
why 85% of all tsunamis happen in the
Pacific Ocean in most cases an
earthquake comes in for a tsunami so if
you're near the coast and you
experienced an earthquake protect
yourself from that first but once the
shaking stops
move to higher ground as quickly as
possible the beach will grow bigger run
the other way an early sign of an
impending tsunami is that the water
along the coast will receive it pulls
back and exposes the seafloor
do not go to the beach to investigate
you'll only be putting yourself at risk
for when the waters
is back instead head in the opposite
direction try to get as far as three and
a half kilometers from the ocean or 30
meters above sea level to ensure your
safety get to the highest elevation
possible tsunamis travel quickly and you
may not have enough time to clear the
hazard zone in this case look for a tall
building with a sturdy concrete
foundation if you see one nearby run
inside and get to the roof as quickly as
possible if you can't make it to a
building in time your best bet is to
grab on to something and hold on though
that might not sound very practical hold
the eye roll for a moment in the 2004
Indian Ocean tsunami an Indonesian woman
was finally rescued after holding on to
a palm tree for five days straight while
it isn't ideal if you can't get to
higher ground in time you need to find
something to hold on to as the tsunami
moves inland it will sweep tons of
debris along with it this can be very
dangerous as the accumulation of debris
traveling at high speeds become fatal
obstacles for anyone who's caught in the
current
however many tsunami victims have been
saved by climbing on two detached roofs
or holding on tightly to floating cars
or other large objects of course if
you've made it this far your troubles
aren't over yet
a tsunami isn't one wave but a series of
waves known as a tsunami wave train
waves may be anywhere from five minutes
apart to an hour apart and be aware that
the first wave that hits isn't always
the strongest so even when you think
it's over stay where you're safe until
you hear from local officials it goes
without saying tsunamis are terrifying
and when a 30 meter wave is hurtling
towards you at eight hundred kilometers
per hour you're probably feeling pretty
helpless but have faith in science trust
empirical research and you'll see
there's always a way out
we'll keep showing you one episode at a
time on how to survive
[Music]
you